foreign
[Music]
good evening everyone I'm Joan Collins
and I am going to be completely
uncensored tonight only a fool only a
fool would think that was a legitimate I
do now yeah you can say it won't believe
you I came to my senses
[Music]
and kicked it
that doesn't mean to me the guy's been
doing the same effing part for 35 years
I kind of only came on here because I
thought it would be kind of funny um but
I want to say you're don't bother me
anymore
how about if you do fight again you have
to give me a million pounds how about
that's a deal if I ask you what a woman
is what would you say
boobs
I've been trying to work out how much
money you must have made from American
Pie if everybody that knows that song
came to my shows I'd be selling out
stadiums we have another several billion
years so if you're gonna prioritize well
that's all right forgive me if I look a
bit sweaty and moist
the girlies apparently liked it that way
no problem with the tits no problem with
the tip no tips aren't really involved
in this it's worth looking for Stanley
oh thank you peers interview adjourned
love you
turn the camera off
president Trump well first of all how
are you very good we're doing well and
it's nice to be in Florida we're sort of
all over the place but a lot of times
spent in Florida what is life like as an
ex-president
well it's uh interesting it's beautiful
it's complex sometimes we have a lot of
endorsements going out and have gone out
we've done very well on endorsing
candidates that I think are very good
and they are very good and we've taken
people from who we're not going to win
and now they're winning big you're
talking like somebody who feels he has
unfinished business
well
we did a really good job we created an
economy that was incredible and now a
supply chain problems inflation problems
gasoline selling for five six seven
dollars think of it a gallon when I left
it was under two dollars and it was
largely under two dollars for a long
period of time 187
167 at one point and now it's five six
seven eight dollars depending on where
you are going up much higher uh and we
have a war that would have never
happened if I was president that war
would have never happened when the
invasion started you were quite
praiseworthy of Vladimir Putin you said
he was a genius this was a Savvy move
but he was going in as a peacemaker no
no that's the fake news's version no
tell me the truth when he built up
soldiers on the border I said that's
very smart brilliant move
because I thought he was negotiating
when he went in I said no longer a
brilliant move when you see the scenes
Mr President of maternity hospitals when
you see refugees being attacked as they
flee grandmothers children babies you
see the decimation of previously
prosperous cities living in a thriving
new democracy when you watch what's
happening I mean do you agree with my
assessment that Vladimir Putin is now an
evil genocidal monster yeah but I also
when I look at I do oh sure who wouldn't
what's happening is horrible when you
see Rockets going into apartment
buildings and there are plenty people in
those buildings you know they think
they're like the people who moved out
they didn't move they want to stay
because they think they're safe in their
Apartments far more people are dead than
you think when I see all the Death and
All That destruction and it's such a
stupid War because yet a country who was
working that was had problems lots of
problems but other the countries have
problems too it was such a horrible
waste to be doing it you see swings
outside you see playgrounds you see
hospitals it was a country
and the people were happy I guess a lot
of them were happy because they're
certainly fighting for it but I'll tell
you what I really think I said isn't it
a shame all those people are dead all
because of a rigged election because if
our election wasn't rigged you would
have had nobody dead when you said to
Putin don't invade Ukraine yeah what was
well I told him what our response was
going to be and his response was really
I said really what did you say your
response and you know what if he
believed me good but if he believed me
only five percent he would have said
I'll never do it well did you say the
responsibility I'm not going to say that
I'm not going to say that but it was a
very strong response but did you
threaten I said for example the nuclear
capability I don't want to talk about
this he's been doing I don't want to
talk about that what I did say is we're
going to be very strongly responding if
you do that I also said to president XI
don't go into Taiwan
and there's going to be a very strong
response they both understood that they
both had the same reaction really
really I said really the thing that may
keep him out of Taiwan is how poorly
Russia is doing right and how vicious it
has to be how horrible it has to be
because China sees that and nobody wants
to see what's happening so what would
you do right now in Ukraine if you were
the President Putin uses the n-word I
call it the n-word he uses the n-word
the nuclear word all the time that's a
No-No you're not supposed to do that he
uses it on a daily basis and everybody's
so afraid so afraid so afraid and as
they're afraid he uses it more and more
that's why he's doing the things he's
doing he's doing them because he thinks
nobody's going to ever attack us because
they're all stupid and they're afraid to
talk I totally agree with you okay so
what'd you do instead of excuse me it's
got a little complicated instead of
you know cow Towing instead of Biden
saying oh
he's got nuclear weapons he keeps saying
he's got new
we have better weapons that we have the
greatest submarine power in history what
would you say and do I would say we have
far more than you do far far more
powerful than you and you can't use that
word ever again you cannot use the
nuclear word ever again and if you do
we're going to have problems my reading
of what you've been saying is that when
you were talking to Putin when you were
president and he was talking about
potentially invading Ukraine that you
threatened him with your nuclear
capability I threatened him like he has
never been threatened before did you
threaten to use nuclear weapon I don't
want to say that I threatened him like
he has never been threatened before
what's your message for Putin now right
now if you could talk to him what would
you say to him I I would say it's a
shame what you've done
you're killing protect I think
potentially look you know if these
people aren't smart and they're not our
leaders are not smart
if they're not smart you're going to end
up in a nuclear war this is just the
beginning this is the beginning and I've
been the best predictor of things ever
now it doesn't have to happen it
shouldn't happen but if our people
aren't smart you can end up in a nuclear
war what's your message she's watching
this interview and he will be look what
would you say I think they're dealing
with them incorrectly I think what
they're saying
it it's almost like they're speaking
with fear and they don't understand we
have
one weapon alone that would destroy
everything the things I'm not happy
about with the presence I'll be
completely straight with you to your
face one of them is what happened on
January 6th which was a result of you
refusing to accept the result of the
election before you start this okay
Nancy Pelosi is in charge of security
she didn't do her job she's half in
charge of it so the Republicans
excuse me the mayor of D.C and Nancy
Pelosi are in charge actually
Republicans and the Democrats have 50
50. but she was actually cowering for
Terror in fear of a life that day
because there was a huge mob of people
if she who are attacking the the center
of Democracy in America if you talk the
talk and you're a great talker I've seen
that today if you taught the talk you
have to walk the walk in the context of
your claim about the fortune election
it's been 14 months and we've not seen
this hard evidence of the fraud that you
say happen the Press won't report it the
press this is like a communist country
it's all over the place we have
because I've watched this whole debate
right and you've been completely
unflagging in your refusal to accept
defeat you know why though you know why
because if our country doesn't have fair
and free elections and if our country
doesn't have borders we don't have a
country okay we have crooked corrupt
elections here's what I would say and
I've proven it and here's what I would
say to you I believe it was a free and
fair election and that you lost I don't
really believe that's my belief well
then you're a fool however then you're a
fool maybe I am a fool maybe I'm the
fool in this conversation and you're a
fool and you haven't studied okay I have
studied it here's the big question for
you are you going to run again well you
know for reasons of campaign finance and
everything I'm not allowed to say but
let me just say this I think a lot of
people are going to be very happy
I I love our country our country is
going to hell I think a lot of people
are going to be very happy you're going
to run I'm not going to say that but I
think people are going to be happy you
might even be happy if it's you against
Joe Biden if you win the Republican
nomination again and he runs again would
you beat him
uh I believe right now anybody I think
you could beat him right now look
there's quite being a fool they've done
a very poor job I don't have to say
anymore they've done a very very poor
job our country's a mess our country has
never been so disrespected our borders
have never been so open we've never had
in 44 years inflation like we have if
you run again and you win
which could well happen and I think
whoever the Republican candidate right
now it looks like the Democrats are
going to get shellacked in the midterms
it's quite likely whoever is a
republican nominee will end up being
president it could be you again
and for as many people who think that's
a great idea you'll know there are lots
of people who think that would be a
total nightmare far less far less I
think so yeah I think for us I think
people are very angry at this country
they're very angry at our leadership
they wish they had their vote to do
again we didn't need their vote because
again we won the election by a
tremendous margin we won the election
actually very easily I haven't mentioned
that's it no yeah yeah no I I realized
I just haven't asked you you're very
descent this was this was a 20-minute
interview listen this was it 20-minute
interview uh I think it's fine it's fine
it's I haven't asked about fantastic in
your opinion I wanted to end with the
hole in one I just haven't asked about
the hole in one do you want to go ahead
you recently got a hole in one playing
golf with Ernie else one of the great
golfers of the world what was that like
yeah well it was great he's a great guy
great player one of the most beautiful
swings they say in the history of golf
and very powerful and I made it with him
and actually three other tour Pros
and it was quite a thrill told me
through the shot
well I hit the ball it was hit well it
felt good the wind was blowing hard into
my face it was a five iron that went 181
yards and it went plank right into the
hole it landed on the Green in one
bounce and it went Plank and
Ernie who's a Loki guy one of the
reasons he's acceptable The Big Easy
right
but Ernie and the other Pros started
jumping up and down in the air and they
said why are you guys so excited he says
because we don't see Hollow ones they
make I guess one every three tournaments
and then you have to be in the group so
it's very do you have one before I've
had seven this was a seven seven this
was my seventh which isn't that high a
number believe it or not if somebody
plays golf
I hear the record is 49 okay people did
you buy a round of drinks in the bar
often I don't know but I would certainly
have been happy to drink I don't drink
now it's traditional you buy around that
is true that is true probably happened I
didn't check but probably happened
because I own the club I'm sure it
happened congratulations all right thank
you very much thank you for a great
interview thank you very much appreciate
it
okay thank you okay let's go that was a
great interview yeah that's fine thank
you very much I really appreciate it
turn the camera off
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Mr President for this lady thank you
both very much indeed I want to ask you
first with the five months into the war
into the sixth month now
how are you both doing how are you
coping with this
how are you doing how are you doing
well if I may say so to be honest I have
this feeling as if it were one day that
is why when it was the sixth day the
seventh day of War since that day I
really have this feeling that all of
this is one very long day
I don't really see the difference
between five months or six months the
only difference is when we feel that at
the battlefield the situation is
stabilized
or we know that at some points in some
positions we are advancing and I keep
thinking about that as you know we are
all human beings and we have to be
strong
sometimes we want to have someone close
to be next to us and that is what you
miss in these moments
yes I miss my children I miss my wife it
is impossible to get used to it
everything else you can get used to
these kind of situations they can make
or break a marriage is your marriage
stronger do you think because of what
you've gone through in the last few
months what do you think I should I have
to begin to answer
okay okay
I agree with the theory that marriage
gets stronger with challenges and I
think in our case it would be the same
we have become more interested in each
other I think in our case it will be the
same story
we have got something else to say to
each other
that is why I want this challenge to
make us more united
what do you think about it my answer
wouldn't be different
Mr President when this war started that
awful night back in February you
appeared very soon afterwards and made a
video address which you put on social
media and I remember watching it in real
time and being very moved by it and it
was really your decision to stay here in
Ukraine and to encourage the people of
Ukraine to fight for their country
some leaders might have left what made
you stay
well it couldn't have gone any other way
because the president is a leader of its
people
the people voted for me and the
strengths of our state
this is something that I have already
mentioned the strength of our state
this is consolidation
this is unity of our people all of us
together the government the people the
servicemen people just want it started
they would go to the streets they would
stop tanks other military vehicles so
the government had to stay in the center
of the decision-making processes
it was very important to make sure that
there is no informational chaos because
we cannot say that this intimidation
works because otherwise they would say
that their informational propaganda
actually won that the government would
leave this is what they wanted
is chaos because chaos is the weakness
of the state
this is the weakness of Institutions on
a more serious no the Russians you're
the number one target for them and your
family is the number two target
that must be a constant pressure for all
of you
but it's not really about you thinking
about your family yes in this case the
family is at the center of attention and
yes this is true
these targets still remain for some
people from the Russian Federation
far as I am concerned I think it is a
given I think that it is a part of this
situation we are in and we are in a
state of War
first lady for you as a mother
to know that the Russians are targeting
not just your husband as president but
you and your potentially your children
your family
for any mother that that must be a
terrifying thought
I tried never to think about this
numbers of targets because when you
think in terms of Target number one
target number two
if you think too much into it then you
can become really paranoid and yes I
understand I'm a mother like many other
mothers in Ukraine that is why all
ukrainians are Targets number two and of
course it's all unpleasant feeling I
don't want to think that they want to do
this to our family what your people have
been saying to me I interviewed a father
in butcher whose son was tortured and
murdered by the Russians and he was very
emotional and when I suggested to him
how would you feel if your president did
a deal with Russia he said no no no no
no and I interviewed two young women
whose apartment block was the last
apartment block to be to be hit by a
cruise missile a month ago the same
reaction instant No Deal they hate yes
they hate and it's understandable when
you when they when so many families lost
for example their neighbors their
children
what the deal
so what the result of this deal
could Russia or can Russia give a child
back no that's why we say no
so there are no emotions only one
emotion hate what is your view of
Vladimir Putin the man who is leading
this war
it is difficult to put it into words
it's not possible to understand how one
crooked idea can throw the whole of
mankind into the Medieval ages
I really don't have words and I really
don't want to say anything aloud because
Normal words don't exist to describe
this
president he is your enemy in this war
he's the leader of Russia they've been
doing despicable things to your people
bombing maternity hospitals committing
war crimes no question torturing people
murdering them what is your view your
opinion of Vladimir Putin
thank you
well it's clear and as you have
mentioned he is Enemy Number One in this
war
it seems to me the scariest thing about
it is that he is in fact sane and he
understands what he's doing I'd say
that's the scariest conclusion I can
make that he understands what he's doing
he knows how many people he kills
he knows how many people were raped and
by who
and the number of children killed or
deported
therefore
I only understand one thing
the world allowed the situation to
develop
it allowed such a person to emerge
with that ideology and attitude towards
people
the world should understand that this
result this mistake to allow this
situation is the responsibility of the
whole world do you believe he would ever
use a nuclear weapon Putin be honest I
don't know I don't know I don't know
what his aims are I don't know what the
Civilized World allows him to do because
if it shows its weakness he will use
everything
do you believe you can win this war
yes no question yeah yeah
I don't only believe it I know it will
happen
we will win
we already showed the whole world that
he can kill us
but to conquer our people is impossible
first lady is it true that he didn't
tell you that he was going to run for
president
say true
well he forgot
he forgot you you got to tell your wife
you're running for president
he understood that probably I wouldn't
have been fond of this idea and that it
would take a couple of hours so very
difficult negotiations with me that is
why probably each day he was thinking
that this is the day that this is the
moment I should tell her you know but he
kept postponing it then it was on TV I
saw his new year's address it was New
Year's night and found out he was
actually running shoes
you found out on TV
Mr President really you announced it on
television before you told your wife
[Music]
I was not laughing so much so loud
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
well Jordan Peterson joins me now John
Peterson welcome thank you it appears
Morgan uncensored I suppose my first
question and there will be people
genuinely wanting a simple answer yeah
but there's a bigger answer too who is
Jordan Peterson well I'm a clinical
psychologist and a professor and I'm
doing that on a broader scale now I
suppose and but it's an extension of
what I've done since
1987 really I mean I I taught the same
things I'm teaching although I've
expanded them
all throughout my academic career and my
classes were very popular and and not
popular exactly
they the students found them extremely
useful why have you become so notorious
because I I look at it as I've actually
watched a lot of your lectures I've
listened to hours of you and Joe Rogan
talking about stuff
I don't see the devil that some people
try and portray you as at all and it
seems to me the one thing we may share
in common is certainly not intellectual
prowess where unfortunately I've many
yards behind you but what we do share I
think is a lot of people seem to have
drawn an opinion about us based on
either what they've seen in a tiny clip
taken out of context a lot of the time
or what they've been told to Think About
You by other people yeah well that's
some of it I mean I got tangled up in a
political controversy in Canada I've
been tangled up I put my foot in it to
some degree because I wasn't very happy
with what I regarded as Government
overreach in relationship to who is in
possession of my tongue and I decided a
long time ago and really a long time ago
that I was going to say what I thought
and sort of independent of the outcome
you know often people craft their speech
you know I could come here on your show
for example I spent half an hour
thinking well what do I want out of this
show but I don't think like that I
wanted to come here and have a
conversation ultimately what is your
goal what is what is the point of Dr
Jordan Peterson what do you hope to
achieve through what is now huge Global
fame
um I hope to encourage people
other than that I want to see what
happens you know I want to say what I
believe to be true as clearly and
and carefully as I possibly can and I
want to see what happens as a
consequence and what people don't
understand about that in some sense is
you happiness the purpose of your life
is not going to be happiness sometimes
it is
sometimes that will come but there will
be difficult periods in your life and
happiness won't suffice that but what
you can have in your life is an
adventure you can have an adventure and
the truth is the best adventure there's
no doubt about that and there's a couple
of reasons for that one is you don't
know what's going to happen if you say
what you think now I don't mean in
cautiously and I don't mean
provocatively or any more than necessary
you don't know what's going to happen so
that's very adventurous but also if it's
you and your voice then it's your
adventure a weird thing happened uh
about two weeks ago I was on Instagram I
suddenly I popped this picture
and it was you with a friend of mine
Cristiano Ronaldo the the Football
Genius greatest player to ever play the
game as far as I'm concerned and you'd
be to see it uh just privately and he
was saying how great it was that he'd
met you and you'd gone there and all
hell broke this he was bombarded with
people saying this is outrageous Legend
over Legacy finished none of which would
have bothered him because he's heard all
this kind of thing before but the Venom
of it was from certain quarters was so
pathetic it seemed to me so first of all
what were you doing with Cristiano why
why were you there well he invited me to
come and see him and um he had had some
trouble in his life a few months ago and
a friend of his sent him some of my
videos and he said he had watched those
and then he read my book one of my books
and found them very helpful and he
wanted to talk so I went out to his
house and we talked for about two hours
and he showed me all his equipment for
keeping himself in Tip-Top condition and
we talked a bit about his companies and
but mostly we talked about what he
wanted in the future and some of the
obstacles that he's facing while
pursuing that and so we had a strategic
conversation I would say were you in a
way were you the Ted lasso figure in his
life well that's what it felt he didn't
realize he was missing yeah well I think
maybe he did realize that he was missing
it because he seemed to have found it to
some degree in those lectures and so and
I was I I always like to hear not only
what people are up to but what they want
and I one of the things I loved about my
clinical practice which was very much
predicated on this like well you're
miserable let's say not to say that he
was because he has a good life in many
ways but
if you could Envision a path forward out
of your misery let's say to somewhere
better what would that look like and
it's not a question people ask
themselves with enough depth and then
having developed that vision
what are the strategies that might be
put in place to make that more likely
and again not in a manipulative way but
if you had to conduct yourself in the
proper manner to bring about this
desirable end or at least to move
towards it how would you how would you
organize your behavior when someone like
Cristiano who you know we know what the
personal problem was he'd lost a baby
and his partner was incredibly sad for
him and professionally after that a lot
of turmoil as to whether he was going to
stay at his club and so on and so on
um it seemed to me talking to him in the
last couple of days after he saw you
he's in a much better place actually
that's what happens when you hang out
like yes but really interesting to me
that so you got and you and he both got
criticized for just seeing each other
um but actually it was clearly very
helpful too well I hope so that would be
lovely if it was true I couldn't really
get my head around why so many young
people feel so anxious all the time
compared to when I was young when it
just that wasn't really a big thing
amongst my friendship groups certainly
but I reckon there's two things one
social media the constant bombardment of
other people having a great time or
looking great often of course imagery
and like having to live up to false
ideals but also a conversation I have
with Dr Phil in America where his
explanation for it was that he said
you've got to understand that social
media means that young people now are
being bombarded all day long and all
night long with quite shocking imagery
and he gave an example he said when I
was young he said if a crocodile ate
somebody on a golf course in Florida the
chances are I would never have heard
about it it probably wouldn't have made
the national news probably wouldn't have
even made the state news and I wouldn't
have heard about this incident now it's
quite likely that a video of the
crocodile eating this person would be
whipping its way around social media
within half an hour and young kids will
be sharing it disseminating it and being
exposed to this constant imagery all the
time of quite unsettling and shocking
imagery what do you think of that theory
and that well I think that in itself was
adding to a sense of everything's
terrible well I think it's a corollary
of an information overload Theory right
I mean one of the advantages to having
to having the computational power we
have is that everything is at your
fingertips and the disadvantage is that
everything's in your face and by
everything it might be 40 million
pornographic images like that's a lot or
an endless array of tragic scenarios and
really endless and so that's a problem
and the problem the fundamental problem
is how do you handle the fire hose of
information and no one really knows the
answer to that but we should also point
out that it's no wonder that young
people are demoralized and anxious
because we're doing everything we can to
demoralize them and make them anxious so
on the masculine front we we tell young
boys that while the world's a terrible
patriarchal tyranny and all of that
patriarchal tyranny which is the whole
explanation for history has done nothing
but oppress and exploit people and
destroy the planet and so that any
manifestation of that masculine impulse
on your part is equivalent to the world
destroying Force when all masculinity
now is branded toxic yeah and I remember
I think the key moment for me came in
Gillette who'd always had these very
masculine commercials with the big guy
cuddling a baby or whatever it may be
they suddenly switch gears and did a
campaign where it started with a lot of
me too imagery and basically the
assumption that all men are awful until
they can prove otherwise and I predicted
in the column this would be a complete
disaster for them and sure enough nine
billion dollars later they did a
screeching U-turn and went back to the
big guy cuddling the babies because
actually two things I think about that
one most men are not awful actually and
so not all the time no some men are
obviously
um some women are pretty awful no but
not most of them but if you try saying
that and not getting canceled um but I
think also this thing that you've got
into trouble about which I don't
understand why that you believe that
most women
probably quite like they're meant to be
strong and confident I don't believe
that all the data shows right clearly a
nice cultural samples and has for 50
years plus everywhere anecdotally most
women I know I think would absolutely
agree why is it that you've been so
vilified for suggesting something which
is so palpably true well I think first
of all that annoys narcissistic women no
end and it annoys people who thinks that
think that there are no biological or
cultural limits on how we manifest our
behaviors and also it it frightens a
large number of women because many women
have never had a good relationship with
anyone masculine in their life and so
the notion that they would need to
establish a trusting relationship with a
man especially if he's also in something
approximating a superordinate position
which is much what they might like to
find him maximally attractive also
implies that they're in some sense going
to be under his Sway and if there's no
trust there well that's absolutely
terrible fine and I have some sympathy
for that because there are no shortage
of women out there who've never had a
positive relationship with anyone
masculine and so they're very they're
completely unable to discriminate
between
narcissistic power and compulsion and
confident competence and so because they
can't distinguish that and they're
afraid they put all of that in the same
category which is something like the
Predator category and and that's not
good for them because well as you said
all men aren't Predators all the time
and they need to establish a
relationship with a man what are your
best traits and what are the the worst
traits of Dr Jordan Peterson
well I think that it's been difficult
for me to to optimally regulate my
irritation at times over the last few
years
and I'm trying to get that right to
figure out what the right because a lot
of things that have happened have
outraged me and then I'm not exactly
sure what emotional tone to take as a
consequence of that outrage and that's a
very complicated thing to figure out and
that's been exacerbated that problem by
the fact that I have been my family and
I have been the targets of very
conniving
um and and attacks and underground
attacks and that isn't stopping I mean
another time when your wife was fighting
a deadly cancer yeah
and so was I so yeah yeah so it's very
difficult to regulate your your temper
properly under those circumstances let's
say and so I don't imagine where have
you most improved yourself do you think
as you've got older
I get better and better at listening you
know and I'm better and better at
finding my way forward with the words
that I choose and that's just it's just
a continual in some sense incremental
expansion having met me enough for an
hour what would your initial clinical
diagnosis be well you're probably
optimally disagreeable for your for your
profession
you know because you can listen but
you're also not a pushover and that's a
very that's a very fine line right
because if you're too assertive or
aggressive then you get domineering but
if you're not enough then you're a
pushover and the film director Olivia
Wilde is a new movie out which yeah she
says it's based on you this insane man
this pseudo-intellectual hero to the
in-cell community in cell being these
weirdo loner men uh who are despicable
in many ways is that you are you the
intellectual hero to these people
sure why not you know
um
people have been after me for a long
time by because I've been speaking to
disaffected young men you know what a
terrible thing to do that is
I thought the marginalized we're
supposed to have a voice
just making emotional talk about it well
God you know
it's very difficult to understand
how demoralized people are and certainly
many young men are in that category and
you get these casual
insults these these in cells what does
that mean it's like well these men
they're they don't know how to make
themselves attractive to women who are
very picky and good for them women like
be picky that's that's your gift man
demand high standards from your man fair
enough but all these men who are
alienated it's like
they're Lonesome and and and they don't
know what to do and everyone piles abuse
on them
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you the most
family issues
um well I want to talk about one in
particular on that which is when you
were late back for the pre-season
training a lot of speculation because
you'd said several weeks before that you
wanted to play Champions League football
and that you were maybe looking for
another option because it didn't look
like United would get to play Let's make
my points for example the preseason
moment and after you mentioned uh
new clubs or interesting for example the
preseason I had a very very bad
which is I don't say nobody the people
who surround me they saw friends and
even my mom I had some problems in
vacation that my young daughter they
have a little problem they have brown
kids which is system conscious
bronchitis yes yes your little baby yes
I was in Majorca and holidays and sister
one week in hospital
which is was
you know you don't enjoy a lot and after
what had happened so what exactly and
the people make make up histories that
they say that I don't want to go travel
because they people have to understand
that I'm a human being I'm always going
to be in my side of my family
I'm not negotiate nothing
behind that you understand
and I even have the the lectures of from
the hospital the the feedback of the
health of Bella which is I'm not sure
nobody nobody asked me I have I keep for
me people forget that I'm human human
being that I passed through a difficult
moments
well you must have been worried sick I
mean you I was very worried baby son and
now your baby daughter's in hospital
exactly and you must have been
absolutely directive of
and the president of Manchester United
and then
kind of that didn't believe
that something going wrong which is make
me feel bad really yes I am yes I didn't
believe you
they believe you but in the same way
they are there and never this ever gonna
change
the health of my family
for a football never
now or
10 years
behind or forwards and it's something
that really hurt me because they doubt
of my words that I struggle especially
Bell and Geo we had one week in hospital
because the Bell have a big problem
and I didn't go to the Precision because
of that because I didn't I didn't
was allowed to left my family if
something happened
to do the Precision because I think it
wasn't not fair to left my family for a
preseason this is why I didn't go
it seemed to me that right from the
start ten Hogg wanted to show you who
the boss was
he dropped you he benched you
he mucked you around
he talked about you in the Press
were you getting that feeling I mean did
you feel that the feeling he always
mentioned to me that I did indeed the
pre-season so I should wait for my
opportunity I really understand I should
well okay I understand
but I'm not gonna give you
points but
it don't do it the same sediment from to
every players I'm not going to mention
players but they don't do it the same
way you don't have a good relationship
with them I'm not mean good relationship
the empathy is not it's not good let's
say you think he respects you
I think you don't you don't respect the
way I should deserve
but
it is what it is this is why probably
the the game against Tottenham well I
want to come to these two games so
against Manchester City where United got
destroyed
he didn't bring you on
he brought other Strikers but didn't
bring you on and
I felt insulted on your behalf I was
like look surely against Manchester City
if you're losing this badly and you've
got the greatest player of all time
sitting there you at least give him some
time don't you excuses
I see as excuses
um okay you don't put me against
Manchester City because of respect of
your career and you want to put me three
minutes against daughter well that's the
thing so then you then play top don't
make sense and then he wants to bring
you on with three minutes to go he was
deliberately provoking him nice for
everyone everyone know that
disrespecting you think exactly this is
why I say I don't have respect for him
because they don't show me respect for
me this is why
we we are we are in that situation I
have to be I have to be honest that the
things done going well because of that
because the empathy don't exist and it
keeps it keeps say things for the Press
but the Press
say what they think it's it's it's good
to protect probably him and Manchester
United but I like guys that they don't
like they speak honest they beat frotel
frontal and I'm not in a good negotiate
my morals my morals always will be
intact that seems to have been the
pattern of the way ten Hargis wanted to
treat you since he became manager just
constant
attempt to disrespect you I guess many
many points happen
I think in some certain points I think
was strategy from the club for me to
react like that because they wanted you
to leave probably yes they're trying to
force you out yes not only the coach but
the other two or three guys there around
the club
at the senior executive level yes that I
felt betrayed
and you think they're trying to get rid
of you honestly I shouldn't say that I
don't know but listen I I don't care I'm
always people should listen the truth
yes I feel betrayed and I felt that some
people that don't want me here not only
this year but last year too
many more you guys are at all no really
yes
the owners of the club they listen they
don't the glazes the glazes they don't
they don't care about about the club I
mean
professional uh
sport
as you know this Manchester is a
marketing Club they will get
his money from the marketing
the sports
it's that that don't really care in my
opinion do you ever talk to them the
glazes never never not since you've gone
back no they give all the power to the
president the sport directive
a lot of Manchester United fans
are very negative about the glazes they
think they're taking all the money out
and are spending enough on players on
the infrastructure issues he talked
about do you think the fans are right
the funds are they're always right I
think the fans should know the true
should know that
the place we want the best for the club
I want the best of the club this is why
you're coming to Manchester United this
is why I love this club
but you have some
things inside the club which is don't
help
to Manchester reach the top level as
City Liverpool and even now Arsenal for
example
which is complicated it's difficult
um
it's hard in my opinion it will be hard
for Manchester to be in the top of the
game
the next two three years do you feel
like you need a fresh challenge
I'd say if it's fresh fresh challenge
but let's say let's say I'm not I cannot
answer right now because my focus is for
the World Cup
but I don't know maybe it's good for
Manchester and berries and probably is
good for me as well
to have a new chapter what is the truth
about other clubs making offers for you
some people have said there were no
offers at all I happen to know that
there was a gigantic one from Saudi
Arabia for example 350 million euros for
two seasons is that okay yes it's true
that's a staggering sum of money yes
which you turned down in that moment yes
I mean that to me says you're not just
about the money I will be honest with
you you don't I didn't have many many
clubs but I have many many offers of the
other clubs which is I didn't change
because I didn't plan to do it but I
have but what the Press keeping saying
the garbage race say that nobody want me
which is completely wrong
and I was happy here to be honest I was
motivated to do it a great season here
but but they continue to repeat nobody
won Cristiano how how they don't want to
play to last year's got 32 goals
with national team I mean that's the
point I don't get because there are
people out there and you see them you
hear them
and they say well he's not the player he
used to be as if somehow at 37 you're
going to be as good as you were at 21.
day by day we're getting old every one
of us you understand it's normal you
have to adapt and I think nobody in this
game
I have this brain that adapts with this
age
I'm not I'm not want to be cocky to say
that I'm the same that when I asked 20
of course no but I'm adopt and I be
smart to know my strength what I'm good
to do and I'm still playing the eye
level and I score goals and I will
continue to score goals Christiana what
a pleasure thank you very much indeed
thank you very much peace very pleasure
for me thank you thank you very much
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]